alors moi les difficultés que j'ai
rencontrées c'est plutôt des difficultés
techniques puisque j'étais pas libraire
avant 2 avant de m'installer donc je me
suis un petit peu
lancé dans le grand bain comme ça et
c'est un petit peu l'apprentissage du
métier sur le tas comme on dit mais les
choses se sont faites à fait
naturellement et puis c'est parti
la difficulté aussi et peut-être d'ordre
financière parce qu'il faut quand même
un stock donc de l'immobilisation
d'argent important alors oui ça c'est
vraiment la partie un petit peu la plus
compliquée sur sur le milieu de la
librairie par rapport en fait aux stocks
a constitué au départ qui va être qui va
être financé quand même assez rapidement
donc voilà on a besoin quand même de
faire des ventes assez vite pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir tourner et ça c'est vrai
que c'est des choses à penser au départ
quand on décide de s'installer sur une
librairie ici ici c'est 80 mètres carrés
des gens taille de propositions très
large
les gens acceptent de commander et
d'attendre oui les gens acceptent
d'attendre nous le retrouverons nous
fait sur baume les dames c'est quand
même qu' il y avait une grosse attente
sur sur le secteur
donc aujourd'hui voilà on a quand même
une clientèle déjà habitués même si ça
fait pas très longtemps qu'on ait
installé et du coup le retour qui nous
est fait on préfère attendre quelques
jours que livre arrive mais vous faire
travailler travailler le commerçant
local
et puis patienter un petit peu parce que
finalement c'est pas très grave de
patienter quelques jours
est-ce que vous vous sentez militante et
si oui de quoi alors militante oui parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une société
de consommation
une société qui est quand même exigeante
on sait très bien qu'on à la concurrence
d'internet un les ventes sur internet
les ventes des grandes surfaces aussi
les ventes des grandes surfaces
également aujourd'hui le côté militant
c'est aussi dire que moi j'ai décidé
d'investir pour offrir un service à la
population locale d'offrir un service de
proximité et aujourd'hui on attend que
la population locale en fait nous
rendent la pareille en venant nous voir
en venant nous demander conseil et en
acceptant également patienter quelques
jours
si le livret panade de faire de faire
venir et de les commander
alors vous considérez militante deux du
commerce de proximité aux militantes de
la culture un peu des deux je pense que
je pense que les choses vont vont de
pair aujourd'hui je pense que la culture
elle doit elle doit s'apprendre dès le
plus jeune âge donc c'est vrai que le
travail aussi qu'on peut faire avec les
écoles avec l'organisation de salons
avec la venue d'auteurs ça c'est le côté
militant culturel et c'est essentiel et
c'est la base
c'est aussi important pour les
générations futures
un enfant qui lie aujourd'hui c'est un
enfant un adulte qui va réfléchir aussi
plus tard donc ça c'est quand même
essentiel et puis et puis après oui
militants sur sur le côté économique et
de commerces de proximité je pense que
ça c'est très très important
est-ce que vous avez entend encore le
temps de lire alors oui le soir comme
tout le monde en fait donc quand la
journée est terminée on rentre à la
maison et puis et puis c'est des soirées
de lecture mais vous arrivez encore à
lire pour le plaisir
vous avez toujours la libraire qui se
disent assez bien ça c'est moins bien
alors moi j'essaye
comme on est plusieurs on essaie quand
même de se répartir de se répartir les
rôles et un petit peu les secteurs de ne
pas lire les mêmes livres chacun et puis
mais oui oui après au départ la lecture
ça reste un plaisir c'est un plaisir
et voilà le seul le seul côté frustrant
c'est il ya tellement de livres qu'on
voudrait pouvoir tous les lire mais
qu'on peut pas